I am Rosa Borras, I am a plastic artist
and I embroider because I need to embroider
cases of missing people in
Mexico and also cases of
murdered people and international cases that
affect me and that I believe must be
remembered through embroidery, there is this
action of memory but also of
demand for justice and to make
the victims visible the gas situation
reaches me Well, through social networks and the
media and it makes me feel
very much desperation a lot of anger
a lot of anguish and I feel that we have to show
solidarity my way of expressing
this solidarity is  through embroidery
and it is specifically through the
figure of Guel that impresses me a lot and
has been a central figure. And so
my way of approaching it has been to
embroider with these embroideries that I am
doing with the names of the children
and the grandson and the wife and now hamsa de
guel I am trying to build bridges
emotional bridges bridges of solidarity
I believe that more actions need to be done
to make visible everything that
is happening in gauze I believe that there is
very partial information and it is very difficult
obtain objective information I think it is
important to go out into the streets I think
it is important to
do more solidarity actions in the
streets